one of the mantras that I repeat over
and over again to myself to my students
is learn to fail or fail to learn
one of the things that I tell my
students about halfway through the class
when it's too too late to drop the class
and they've already gotten to know me a
little bit better I tell them that I
wish them that they fail more and I
truly sincerely mean it because it's
only through failure that we can learn
it's not true and it's through failure
and that we can enjoy deep learning it's
through failure that we become more
resilient and stronger and if you look
at the life of any successful person
they've always had major as well as
minor failures
Thomas Edison has patented 1093
inventions more than any other scientist
inventor in history he's also the
scientist as far as we know who has
failed the most times in fact when he
was working on one of his inventions a
battery and a journalist came over and
said to him you know Edison you have
failed 1,000 times and give it up to
which he responded I haven't failed five
when Edison was working on on a battery
one of his inventions an interviewer
came over and and said to him in in the
in the interview Edison you have failed
thousand times give it up
to which Edison responded I haven't
failed a thousand times I've succeeded a
thousand times I've succeeded in showing
what doesn't work Edison also famously
said I failed my way to success